[Music]
hi I'm Courtney coupe and I am the head
of great big story all week long we've
been celebrating great big voices and
telling stories about the individuals
who inspire us to be bold and embrace
our own individuality Kol and charisma
are two people who were featured in our
series the brave which recognizes people
who have big and brave ideas and prove
to us that change and progress really
are possible and you guys are doing that
through your vlog roll with : charisma
yes we try to yeah you are an inter
abled couple who basically want to be a
resource for other Internet couples and
also just show that your love story is
just as real as any other absolutely and
I have to say watching a lot of your
videos on YouTube that's definitely the
takeaway that I got
it's just what an incredible
relationship so let's talk a little bit
about that love story and how you met
it was after your accident Kol that left
you as a quad so yes what does that mean
what is your your daily function like
yes so as a quadriplegic
I have no function from here down and so
that also includes my hands so I can't
use my hands and I can't use my triceps
so if I reach up here mom just Falls and
I can't stop that and I learned the hard
way I got to dodge my hand because
otherwise it was a vase so a paraplegic
for example as opposed to a quad would
have all their arm function and hand
function and all of that so a lot of
people think that since I can move my
arms I'm not a quad but really that's
not the case I am absolutely a
quadriplegic okay
so YouTube Matt at the rehab facility
yes you were doing rehab and you were
attack so charisma mm-hmm
what was the spark that is initially
treated coal I just thought he was
really cute honestly I didn't really
notice him until my friend I pointed out
that he had a girlfriend and I was like
oh like who's that case of yes you know
once you get the girlfriend all the
girls come after you yeah
yeah so I broke up with that girl and I
was well no that's made the first move
well I had gone over to where he was
working out and asked if they need any
help what kind of a ways that I kind of
talked to Cole and they did need help
and they need the help getting Cole off
the bike so that's kind of where we
first interacted and then we truly had a
conversation and kind of flirted when we
were at the gala hosted by sheltering
arms the same rehab hospital mm-hmm and
then from there I felt : Instagram he
pulled me back like a couple my pictures
like couple his pictures and then he
deemed me and the rest is history
which is how I heard a great
relationship it's very Millennial
meeting story but I got the girls so I
have no shame yeah was there any
hesitation I'm either one of your parts
well I would say I only hesitated
because I was just emerging at that
point from a space where like a mine
space where I wasn't super confident yet
and I was just beginning to put myself
out there again because I went for a
long time when I didn't date at all and
I think it was like an image issue that
I had with myself because before my
injury I was very much athletic jock
type that was always chasing the girls
and after I became injured and I lost my
athleticism and what I felt like was my
masculinity to that was much more
difficult for me and so charisma helped
break me out of that show and I'm glad
that I had I had just enough confidence
to get her out on a date so what was
that time I'm like how old were you when
you had your injury and how old were you
guys when you started dating I I was
injured at 16 and then we started dating
it was a I'm not good with calendar days
or your age you just don't need that I
was 24 so we're a year right we are in
your apartment so you say I've heard you
say that before that you doubted that
you would ever be able to find yeah a
relationship yeah so what was it about
charisma that made you realize she's so
charismatic
he's just so darker
I think I don't know it was just the way
we clicked on the first date I mean I
pulled out just enough confidence like I
said to get her out and then it was just
so natural and I didn't feel like I had
to worry about you know my chair my
situation and then she was really open
with asking questions about it too so it
wasn't like she was creating this taboo
subject around my chair and that made me
feel much more comfortable as well yeah
working in the hospital I've worked with
people you know in wheelchairs and I'm
pretty aware of spinal cord injuries I
didn't know like fully to what extent
Cole you know his ability and what he
can and can't do but I was just so used
to being around people and wheelchairs
are with a disability it just really
didn't faze me I mean I just saw him for
him and I saw the person so Cole so yeah
at what point did you both realize that
this was something special that this was
more than just a casual person that you
were dating well by the end of our first
date I was already setting up how I was
gonna message her that night yeah same
I'd like thought of a song and I was
like I'm gonna text you the song later
anyway I knew from this from very
beginning that I mean this was something
special I mean I wasn't sure like at
that point per se that I was like ready
to spend the rest of my life of that
girl like that came on later on like as
we our relationship grew and grew and
grew and our love for each other did as
well then it was like I mean a few
months I was like alright this is the
real deal yeah let's keep this thing
going yeah it's actually really funny
because my side story is different but I
I mean I I have dated before like Cole
isn't you know my first relationship and
I've had a really long relationship so
when I met Cole I knew from like Dave
wine like I first date that he was the
one I went to immerse my like but just
because like I have experienced other
guys and like you when you meet the one
after like experiencing what you don't
want you know what you want and when you
meet that person you're like okay this
is it so what is the easiest thing to
love about him his question that's
that's more of these going
I mean it's personality is positivity I
mean he always makes me smile every day
and even when I'm like upset like he
won't let me be upset like
pasok a minute here's like Aria Chris my
like you're done like trying to be happy
is just he's always making me laugh and
smile and it's I don't know I just yeah
it's just his personality it's just
great he's always happy and positive all
right so what's the easiest thing to
love about her well the first thing that
drew me to her was her smile because how
can you not love that with the dimples
and all that but her her character I
think is very similar to mine too like
she says that she leans I'm high
positivity but I've leaned on hers a lot
as well and that can be hard sometimes
when I try to be positive but I mean
like anybody there's a up their ups and
downs and when I don't have myself to
lean on anymore
if I don't have somebody else there to
bring me back up then I'm sorta at a
loss so charisma is that someone else
for me she's there I can only imagine
that something that the two of you have
to deal with a lot is the perception of
other people so how often are you met
with surprise or speculation about what
your relationship is it's interesting
you ask because I just got a question
for you things in yeah
I've got a question for the first time
on our flight here the flight attendant
as I was being transferred into our seat
on the plane and charisma was helping
break down my chair and take the
batteries off because they can't go into
cargo hold and all the stuff that goes
into flying the flight is in ascent oh
she here and your nurse or your aide I
said oh no that's my girlfriend and she
kind of looking at oh I was like hmm so
there's an assumption there that she's
just helping me and we're not together
and I wonder sometimes if that's because
she's black too so I think the
combination really throws people off
there are a lot of stereotypes that
exist and we are trying to buck them but
they're there well so what do you do in
those situations yeah
let's make you feel awkward of the two
of you generally shut those down what do
you say well I don't really care like
they don't bother me very much and so I
just kind of laugh about it and I
continue and I I always carry my own
assumption that people aren't trying to
be offensive so they're not trying to be
mean so I just you know I don't like get
insulted mm-hmm I mean there's also this
assumption that I have a big heart and
I'm an angel because I'm not cool and
your noble yeah and and I don't like
that because it it makes me feel like
people have to have a big heart to be
with someone in a wheelchair or with a
disability and that's not the case like
I mean you love the person for the
person um
and so when people do you say that I'm
just kind of like no like I just love
him for him like my heart is no bigger
than anyone else's because we're
together so I just say that but that's
about it so I think that you are
addressing a lot of these myths and
misconceptions and bias with 3-year vlog
so what made you want to start capturing
that and telling those stories and
telling your story mm-hmm well it was my
idea originally um we were just in the
car knows okay do you want to start a
vlog he's like sure okay yeah he wasn't
really on board at first but we can I
just pulled out my phone and we started
recording we were like oh this isn't too
bad and so we got a camera like the next
day and then recorded some more and
threw together a video and uploaded it
and from there just I know came natural
yeah it did I really was lukewarm at the
beginning but then I found how much I
enjoyed going out and filming new things
trying new things like she's always
pushing me out outside of my comfort
zone to do all these adventures and also
enjoy the editing process and creating
something that I could be proud of and I
can show other people and that they
appreciate as well and then I think what
really drives at home like the value of
the channel is when you know we we get
the affirmation from people watching
saying wow like this is really awesome
like thank you for sharing this with us
and you know I had a really bad day
today but I was able to draw some
positivity from your video and smile
even though you know
something just happened we're lost a
family member whatever the case may be
we just were happy that we were able to
bring happiness to others what is the
feedback then both from the community of
other inner a bold couples and then from
people who perhaps have never seen an
inner abled couple before have had their
own biases and and the things that
you're doing to help kind of course
correct that okay um I think a lot of
times you know that assumption that I'm
with him for like reasons that may not
be about him like I don't love him or
something like that I think when people
actually see the love then they realize
okay people do they do love each other
and it's not like what they may think
but also like even outside of the inner
Abel relationship I think that people
view disabilities differently so you had
a lot of comments from people who are
able-bodied and they say you know before
they saw our channel when they saw
someone in a wheelchair they wouldn't
look at them because they felt steering
was wrong and so they looked away but
now they say they just say hi to them
and like you can see like the big smile
on their face and makes them feel so
much better one of my favorite comments
that we've received is someone said you
know I've been watching you guys for a
while and I don't see Cole's chair
anymore I just see Cole like yes that's
it that's the whole idea because I want
people to see me as a normal person
because I'm a normal person I just have
an abnormal way of getting around and as
soon as people start not seeing the
chair so much and just seeing another
person then all of a sudden our
relationship becomes very normal yeah
because it is a normal relationship we
have normal problems our problems are
more about like communication and like I
didn't tell her that I scheduled
something and you know that we argue
more about that then you know anything
to do with my disability so we just want
people know that's a normal relationship
well so you kind of just answered this
question but so then why is it important
for you for people to see a relationship
like yours we want everybody to know
that there are so many different ways to
love in so many different forms of
relationship and I think where did we
just happen to be a good example of a
unique form of love
and then for people to understand like
they're not I mean you can see close
disability is obvious but there's also
invisible disabilities so I also think
it brings awareness to not only
wheelchair users but people who may have
a hearing impairment or they may have a
vision impairment or even mental health
issues like that's still a disability in
itself so I think it opens people's eyes
to disability as a whole
yes disabilities so you put your
relationship on the Internet yeah the
Internet can be a dark and scary place
like there are a lot of trolls and
people who can hide behind their
anonymity do you find that you're more
often met with positivity or negativity
oh it's absolutely positivity I would
say 99.9% but there are trolls out there
who want to bring in the negativity and
we don't know if it comes from a place
of jealousy or like genuine dislike
whatever the case may be but there has
been some negative stuff I don't really
get affected by it but I mean well words
can hurt ya and it's it's interesting
enough like a lot of the negative
comments we do get they're kind of
directed more towards me than cold like
maybe 80% about me nobody wants to
attack the kid in a wheelchair so the
next easiest target is charisma yeah so
you know um it was hard to deal with
that and just look past it in that let
it affect me I mean it took a couple of
months but now it doesn't bother me as
much but there's also like this way you
can be like block certain words which we
had to do which is really sad like the
words we have to choose the block but
I'm very aggressive words we didn't like
that many but some we're just disgusting
yeah did you remember take that into
your relationship and have it affect you
or is that actually something that made
the two of you stronger together I think
it may have affected us at the beginning
because I don't think like coal is very
it's very easy for coal to like let go
of something and not let it affect them
but for me it wasn't as easy so I think
from his perspective he's like Christmas
just let it go don't leave bother you
like no have thicker skin kind of thing
for me it was really hard so I think it
took a while for you to understand like
how it affected me why affected me but
the answer the second question is also
yes I think it did make it stronger
because anytime you go through something
like that together that's emotionally
trying or challenging and there might be
some tension there whenever you work
through that you always come out on the
other side stronger so keep sending us
the negativity is just making us
stronger yeah so we call this
conversation why I'm in it and I think
that's a really interesting question to
ask any couple in a relationship and I
think you got this opportunity to speak
to those people who say that you
shouldn't be together you shouldn't be
together because of how different the
two of you are but so why are you in it
why is it worth it it's love yeah I mean
what I know it's cliche but what would
you do for love yeah I would put up with
any comment any stairs whatever because
I want to be with her and we choose to
do a youtube channel because I hope that
that inspires all the people to not care
either you know just do what you want to
do if you find love wherever you find it
chase it and don't let anything slow you
don't very well so you've been together
for a year and a half she's better with
how is your relationship evolved hmm um
I don't know I feel like we've had that
connection from the beginning so that
connection was always there but I guess
yeah I don't know I guess we've grown as
people you know together but also
individually I think we've evolved at
this point past dating like we're
partners now yeah and I know that
usually is attached with like marriage
and stuff like that and when I feel like
I have a life partner because we spend
most our time together we have a
business together we have a relationship
together
so we're partners in life and that has
been an awesome evolution to experience
because I went from having a girlfriend
to a partner that was really cool that's
so incredibly adorable so where do you
think it's going so of course people
don't want to see us married and with
kids
coming yeah that's coming you know we're
doing it on our own timeline that's
appropriate for us but when we whenever
we answer that question we always think
in terms of our you know our business
and how our partners in that way and
when when we talk about that I mean it's
really exciting to us that we don't
really have an answer and in five years
we could be anywhere I mean if you asked
me a year ago where I would be I would I
would never have said you know in New
York doing an interview and have with a
YouTube channel with however many
subscribers we have only to know this
way so I mean it's just it's more
exciting for us to not know where we'll
be in five years and just be ready to
embrace whatever opportunities come our
way and that's just I hope we'll be
somewhere cool but as far as our
relationship goes I definitely see us on
a beach in Tahiti you know with our
triplets running around somewhere and a
Christmas chasing all of them and I'm
like you doing great babe just get him
he went that way
and she she went that way I think the
most important thing to take away if you
would ask your 15 year old self where
would you be when you're 23 I'm not sure
you would have said here oh there's no
shot but the beauty of the answer to
that question is there's no doubt that
the two of you will be together yeah
yeah we actually answered this question
before and a vlog and people responded
kind of interestingly because I just I
was using we as mean charisma but I
never like explicitly said charisma
people oh he didn't say her name I was
like whoa I didn't even think about that
because it was so obvious to me that we
would be together yeah and so this time
I'm saying I will I will be with
charisma whoever we are thank you guys
both for joining me today for sharing
more of your experience in your story
everybody should definitely head to
great big story to check out the episode
of the brave that leaves it with :
charisma it was a lot of fun filming
that yeah thank you so much thank you
thanks
you
[Music]